Yeah.
Hey, what's going on it's spilled? Burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and
just checking in on you. I'm
just checking in on you. Du,
Du, Du, Du. Hey, guess what? What? I uh,
I am fucking on it this year when it
comes to Christmas. Hey, Christmas.
Go Fuck Yourself. That's what I'm
saying. I'm talking all kinds of shit.
I'm backing up. I'm wagging my
fucking head at your Christmas.
I'm sorry.
I'm just excited.
I got all my shit wrapped and I
shipped it out today. Fuck you over.
Over.
That's it. All I need to do is
get a pair of Jordans, right?
Whatever the fuck verse he says
in, in, that's it. It's over.
The greatest fucking feeling ever
this holiday is like, you know,
when you become an adult, it's dreadful.
It's like, Oh fuck man, I gotta. You know,
I got to bring the kid over here.
I got fucking get this person something.
Oh Jesus, what do I gotta get this guy
a calendar or something. I got to show,
I got to show them how much I care about
is stories that have no fucking point,
you know,
got at least get them a stocking stuffer
for how many minutes of my life did he
waste this year. Just the, the, the,
the, the fucking stress of that.
Um, I gotta tell you something by,
in the things and wrapping him,
slapping a name on them and then once
you mail that fucking thing I do,
it's like a high, it'd be like
runners talk about like runner's high,
you know,
which is hilarious because if you look
at the look on their face when they're
running, it does not look like
they're enjoying themselves.
Every person I've ever seen jogging
down the street, like not everyone,
but most of them, they look like they
should acquit. Like two miles ago,
they'll lean into one side. They kind
of got that fucking stroke mouth going,
you're not the fucking one. It's
like to just enough, already enough.
We get it. We get it, we get
it. You're a, you're, you're,
you're a fitness fucking grew guru. Slow
down. Walk. Go over to that Taco stand.
All right. Get yourself a fucking
Taco with something. All right.
Just relax. Um, who do you hate
more joggers of bike riders?
Yeah. Who Do you hate more
joggers of bike riders? Neither.
I like everybody on the poverty of force.
It balances out your life.
Get the hell out of my office.
And you crushed on the podcast.
Let's see if you've got another one in.
You don't hit me. I gotta go. I gotta
go to the gym by you go into the gym.
What folder you all Hollywood.
You're trying to get you
abs going for 2018. Yeah,
a beefcake.
Alright,
bye. Um, oh wait.
Oh is the anticlimactic then
you got to come back. Come on,
give me a kiss goodbye. Let me kiss
goodbye. Actually, you know what?
Give it to me when I come when you come
home. All right, I'll see. Asshole.
Gross. Oh, I got all the tags.
Nia for the gifts and stuff.
Yup. And I try to make your Nia when
I said from uncle bill and aunt teeny,
I try to make it look like
your handwriting, but it
clearly looks like mine.
It doesn't need to be.
Plus I'm left handed so it's smudged
across and I forgot to sign your name to
the card. The one that said
how much we care about them.
It's the second time I've done that.
You are the work.
There's going to be a lot of
Hosta. I didn't do that to
you. You need I'm kidding.
Come back please.
I'm
the fucking Shit that women are into
is just, you know, she got a card.
Did sign my name to what
about yeah. All right. I mean
how could you do that? How everybody's
getting sick. I don't care.
No they're not. They
have lives. Um, anyways,
I got this shit fucking rap.
I got,
I got like one more thing to get my wife
and have all of that fucking wrapped.
All right. And I just see, here
you go. Alright, here you go.
Leave me alone and then I'm gonna, I
gotta like eloquently come off the wagon.
I'm still on the wagon. I
got 15 weeks in. All right.
I'm already a third of the year
in 26 weeks is half a year,
but that takes me into February and
I'm going to the rose bowl so that,
that's the next tough one.
That's the next hurdle I have to get
past is if I could somehow go to the rose
bowl and not get all fucked up,
which I've done before. I've done it.
I've done, I think I've done a couple of
times. I've done the Rosebowl sober. Um,
I don't know what, but, uh, I'm
actually, I was thinking the other night,
like when I come back to drinking,
all right?
When we rekindle our relationship,
you know, like you have a c,
there was a particular person out here in
Hollywood, had an abusive relationship.
Skye was beating the shit out of her and
stuff, and then she went back to him,
you know, being like, no,
we fixed it this time.
And I remember the talk show
hosts were like going like,
are you sure you know what you're doing?
This is me going back to Boosie. Um,
with my little barbed wire tattoo,
um,
I think I'm just going
to go straight to heroin.
Like I for some reason feel
like I can handle it at my age,
you know,
cause I know how stupid it is to do.
I would just do it like one time and
just be sitting there like right in the
living room to just don't, don't have
the shame that most junkies have.
You just sit down with your
family. You just say, listen,
this is something that I want to try.
I'm just gonna do it once and I would
appreciate it if you guys would hang out
during my entire high and make sure that
I don't tip over and bust my head open
on the coffee table with, even though
we have the kid proof things around it,
it'd be actually a lot of that kid proof
shit becomes junky proof after a while.
You know,
I'm,
I'm kidding and I'm not making light
of the nationwide heroin epidemic,
but we all know that the nationwide heroin
epidemic is not the biggest story in
the country right now.
That's not the biggest story.
It's not that they've poisoned our food
supply fellow Americans. It's not that.
It's not that after all the protests,
they're still gonna put that
fucking pipeline and it's not that.
What is the biggest story?
Huh?
Matt Lauer buying a fucking Dildo
for the stand in weather person.
It's not that
having a president who's out of his fuck.
Nate's not debt.
The biggest story in the United States
of America right now is Eli Manning is
being sat on Sunday and it's 210 game
streak is coming to a close and all of New
York shot down.
They couldn't believe that Alicia Manning,
I didn't know his name was Alicia.
I have never seen such a
fucking ridiculous reaction
while ignoring real fucking
problems.
There's like 30,000 fucking tornado or
whatever the fuck we had. Hurricanes, Eh,
fuck all that. Miami is giving
you on the water like Dilla.
The fucking texts that I got from
New York sports fans, my friends,
like the level that they were
having a fucking meltdown, you know,
fuck the rope.
A dope that's going on in the Middle East
right now where you got a fucking band
,
a fucking 3,500 nitwits bankrupting a
billion dollar company is they got a bag
of rocks that were flying. F
eighteens, Adam blowing all our cash.
Fuck all of that.
Eli Manning is being sat on Sunday.
I got a buddy of mine.
He flipped out so bad.
He's actually betting against the
giants. It's like, dude, if Gino sucks,
which I don't think he's going to,
no one knows how good Geno Smith is.
He played on the jets.
No one knows how good anybody is when
they play for the jets. The jets,
sorry, everybody out in Queens. But you
know there's an element of truth to that.
Okay. The patriots used to
be like that. All right,
so there is hope for you guys.
God knows bill Belicheck is 70 years old
and we all saw Tom Brady try to recover
that bad snap last week. Right. You saw
when he was running after that thing,
he looked his age.
He looked like a guy who forgot to set
his parking brake and was still hobbling
after his fucking car and then realize
like, I'm not going to break my leg.
I don't fuck it. I got insurance on this
car and it just flopped on the ground.
Um,
deaf geno Smith shits the bed.
Eli's going to be back in the second
quarter. All right. And by the way,
this happens to every quarterback.
No matter how good they were,
no matter how good of
a class act they were,
this happens to everyone to fuck happened
to Peyton manning after all those
years of standing there with at least
19 inches of his 42 inch neck exposed
between his helmet in his shoulder pads,
it finally fucking gave out.
And what did that fucking Guy Jim or say,
ah,
the fucking national enquirer
of fucking sports owners.
He turned his fucking back on him.
Okay.
It Peyton manning, he went to fucking
eastern Europe. He went to Transylvania,
right?
And he got fucking child's blood pumped
into his fucking do whatever the hell it
virgin blood pump did do his fucking neck.
And he comes back to Jim Rsa and says,
[inaudible] right,
whatever that whatever the fuck he talks,
why don't you put me in
this week? Whatever the fuck
he said to them, you know,
probably make more money doing that.
And I had a board larger. Right?
What did Jim or say say he said Peyton,
with all due respect,
fuck you and your fucking
three feet and neck.
We'll move on on bore tank in the rest
of this season so we can get Andrew Luck.
That's what the fuck happened. Look what
happened at Brett [inaudible]. Right?
Be fucker. He actually had to
go to the jets. Eli Manning,
all these guys with his
quiver and bottom lip.
All he's gotta do is sit on the fucking
bench for a couple of place. That's it.
Okay.
It's all you got to do.
Everybody losing their fucking minds.
How could they do this?
How could they do the exact same fucking
thing that they don't? Everybody.
You remember the end of Derek Jeter,
his career when all those sports
writers will fucking bitch and a bottom.
Sandy's a, he's costing the
team. He's too fucking old.
Should they move him over to first base?
This happens to everybody. You know.
You don't think that
talking about me right now?
Yeah.
The way I'm fucking look in these days.
I have like three friends of mine
that are are, I love the, the,
the biggest New York fans ever.
And I,
I got like fucking phone book
level texts about what was going,
you think it's going to
end pretty with Tom Brady?
This guy wants to play to least like 60.
It's some 0.0 fucking Bob Kraft is going
to have to sit down and be like top,
it's you're too old. I mean, look at yet
you still have a Beatle mania haircut.
What fucking year did
you come in the league?
Yeah.
You got a fucking Moe Howard haircut
with the fucking part. I mean,
I don't even know what to tell fucking
Bill Clinton was still president when you
came in.
Yeah.
MMM. I don't know what to tell you.
Uh, this happens to everybody. Yeah.
It's obviously a shame. Eli's
fucking great. Uh, I got to tell you,
it's sucks is a patriots fan watching
the giants just fucking dismantle.
And I wanted one more crack at them.
We had nothing to lose.
You already kicked our ass fucking twice.
We'll come back like tex
Cobb for a third one.
And I was loving and there would always
be an asterick even if the giants made
the Superbowl. And even if with the
Patriots made the Superbowl this year,
if came back without Tom Kauflin and we
won that one, that still would be at,
that still wouldn't be the same.
They went.
That's the level of respect that I have
for fucking the giants organization,
Tom Kauffman and Eli, Alicia Manic. I'm
just breaking your balls. New York fans.
I know. It sucks. You know what?
It really is all you guys flipping out
and you're acting like you love Eli
Manning,
but you really are,
is you're a bunch of selfish cons
because watching Eli gets benched,
it's just reminding you of how
fucking old you're getting.
And now we're all gonna die.
It reminds you of your own mortality.
So rather than deal with that,
you call in sports shows
losing your fucking voice,
you know?
And meanwhile we're fucking blown $1
billion a month fighting people who have
slingshots and a bag of
dynamite. Um, anyway,
um, I swear to God, if I was running,
this is how I would handle isis.
I would just fucking
take, I would, I would,
whatever those fucking gamers are that
actually got to play on the giant TV
screen in Dallas Cowboys Stadium.
If you're good enough to do those
guys with those drone races in,
in that stadium, like that would
be my defense against Isis,
some intelligence and that I have those
fuckers sitting in cowboys stadium where
the cowboys didn't have a game and I
just have them flying around, you know,
blowing up at jungle Jim's. I mean,
that's how I would handle it. Okay.
And considering I haven't even physical
fiscally researched this on any level.
I haven't talked to anybody who is even
remotely informed about what's going on
over there. The fact that I did this
in my own self contained think tank,
I cannot even begin to describe to
you how much this makes sense to me.
You know, come on dude, you got,
you don't sit by yourself sometimes
and just start solving all the world's
problems. You start walking
around your house whispering,
pretending you're getting interviewed by
Oprah. Come on. We all do this though. We,
okay.
Oprah sitting across from you,
do you consider yourself a hero?
Um,
is you sit there and muttering to yourself
and then somehow you come into your
fucking present,
need you to sit in this scrubbing like
a fucking old rice checkoff a bowl,
and you have that split second of just
really stepping outside of yourself.
It'd be like, well, I'm really,
I'm a fucking crazy person.
Yeah.
And then all of a sudden the front door
opens and your family walks in and you
go right back into character
and they have no idea.
Could you stand in there with this
phony smile and awareness sweater?
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Anyways, a happy trails.
Matt Lauer, you know,
you did a hell of a job waking
everybody up, uh, for the last 20 years.
And uh,
okay.
Yeah,
you got a little sideways.
Oh,
okay.
How do you buy a sex toy for somebody
you work with and then write a letter?
I mean, Jesus for when it's
just walk around with a
fucking neon sign around your
goddamn neck. I swear to God,
did people get this successful?
And they just like want access
avatars their own fucking career.
Although maybe he's just like old school.
He came in,
he came in the league when that he was,
I don't know when you could do that
because you've got to think when he first
started buying like
fucking shit like that.
If it was the late nineties when you
think about the cell phone technology,
texting didn't even exist. There was
none of that shit. There was no Facebook,
there was nothing.
MMM.
I mean, what could, that won't pull a
woman. Do Rick run off a bunch of copies,
put them on telephone
poles? It just, you know,
and then you just have an assistant
run out and tear them down.
Matt Lauer screaming from the
window. I said, turned out right?
Um, I dunno. I Dunno.
Anyways, I'm going to be in New
Mexico, in Albuquerque, New Mexico,
southwest. Part of the state,
I mean as part of the country,
and I'm going to be an Arizona
this weekend. Come on down.
I mean at the route 66 casino. Where
the fuck am I going to be in Arizona?
I like Arizona Doodah Doodah because
it's only an hour away on a southwest
flight. Again, on the fucking plane.
I listened to this stupid jokes.
Then they say,
we're beginning our initial descent.
Please raise all your tray
tables in your seats please.
How come this fucking thing isn't loading?
Why is my signal flow work?
Okay?
Oh, Jesus Christ. Well, we'll get
back to this, by the way, by the way,
thank you for everybody who's buying
tickets to the Patrice O'Neal comedy
special. I'll comedy benefits. Sorry,
I'll be promoting this right
up until February, Tuesday,
February 20th,
2018 7:00 PM at the city
center in a New York City,
the sixth annual Patrice O'Neal
comedy benefit, benefit, benefit,
and we keep adding more people.
All right.
We just added the Great Jim Norton,
Jannie Norton,
a Brendan Burns, p Cory La
Jota, Rosa, Sam j, Robert Kelly,
Jessica, Kirsten Sifa
sounds and rich Vos, uh,
and myself will be,
they're honoring the memory of the
best standup comedian I ever saw live.
All right.
And where am I going to be in Arizona?
I'm going to be at the
desert diamond casino. Well,
I'm just a fucking dirt bag this week
or and I route 66 casino in the desert
diamond casino in Sahar route.
I Sahuarita Saturday,
Arizona.
This is the degenerate tour.
Um,
and then on December 10th
I just added this date.
I'm going to be at the island [inaudible]
theater in Santa Barbara, California.
All right. Santa Barbara.
Speaking of Oprah Winfrey,
one of our giant houses is up there.
Maybe she'll show up to the show.
MMM.
[inaudible]
I'm going to be up there.
And then December 14th it'll be at
the hard rock live in Hollywood,
Florida in December 16th. Bob
Carr Theater in Orlando, Florida.
And on the 15th, I'm going to the magic.
I got to get some tickets for that,
by the way. I got to figure out what
the fuck I'm doing over there. Um,
anyways, should I read some
advertising here? What else did I want?
All my ribs are feeling better. In case
you were asking case, you were wondering.
I got misused and I'm
trying to lay off the drums.
I'm trying. Um, did I mention that I'm
building a drum room finally in my house.
I've had it. I've had it with having
to drive to go to my fucking drums.
Just having a kid now you gotta wait
till they take a nap and then you run out
there and for fucking 20 minutes
to an hour and six minutes,
he play fucking drums with the
little kid monitor there. Right.
So you can see when she gets up,
then they go back and that's how I'm going
to do it. That's, that's my game plan.
Um,
you know what he actually did,
I have almost every modern
drummer from the 1980s. And,
um,
I was looking at him the other day and uh,
I saw that old Steve Jordan one that
they didn't like 86 or 85 where a Dave
Garibaldi broke down his ghost notes and
all that Shit for messing with the kid.
I gotta get that down. I got
to learn that shit. That's,
that's my next fucking goal. All right?
My goal isn't to become a better person.
My goal is to recreate what was already
created and then hope that somebody
notices and is impressed by
me. Um, all right, let's read,
we've got four reeds here today.
Can you guys hang in here and listen
to me read out loud for the next few
minutes? Okay. If you think the bullshit
I was saying was remotely amusing,
this part will be hilarious.
We're exposed really my level of
intellect. All right. Tipsy elves,
everybody.
Everyone needs an ugly Christmas
sweater this time of year.
If you want bragging rights for the most.
Talked about sweater at your
Christmas parties. Listen Up.
Talk about your tipsy elves sweater and
other products you saw on the website.
I've yet to go on it.
I don't know anything about these.
I know that hipsters love this
shit. Hey hipsters. Here we go.
Tipsy elves has hundreds of Christmas
sweater designs that are like nothing
you've seen before. This is where
they show my, I show my age.
I don't think Christmas sweaters are
ugly. I think they're very festive. Uh,
that it's like wearing an oriental
rug that has like snowmen on it. Um,
they're not for the faint of heart.
Be The life of the Party with
Hilarious Leigh or reverent designs.
All right, let me look this shit up.
Let's see what fucking tipsy elves is.
Bring it to the table here. All right.
This saying they're fucking hilarious.
I sit there saying I'm remotely amusing
and these kinds have the balls to come
on and start talking all this shit.
You know,
like they just put out a Chris rock
level. Fucking special. Alright.
Tipsy elves.com. All right,
let's see what they got here.
Let's see. Jesus. Okay. All right.
These guys are definitely bringing it.
What the fuck?
Uh,
oh my God.
Yeah.
They got an Obama one that
says miss me yet on the back.
They should have all his drone attack
with a list of all the people who weren't
terrorists. Can we fucking be balanced
in this country? Jesus fucking Christ.
I don't understand this hero
worship of that guy. I really don't.
What did he do? You know what
the best thing about Obama was?
He could deliver a fucking speech,
you know,
and I don't even know how
good he was considerate.
He was in between Bush and fucking
Trump. So that's really like, you know,
that's really setting
the bar for like low. He,
he finally won Shane [inaudible] and
you're not going to fool me again. I mean,
how do you not follow that? And then
I don't know what this other guy said.
Donald Trump is so fucking batty.
I actually had this thought the other day.
Well thank God Mike Pence is in there.
Um, okay. I got to give it up to
these guys. Tipsy elves. Yeah.
If you want to fucked up look and
sweater, these guys are definitely, uh,
they're definitely crushing it.
I like the suit though.
I going to be honest with you. I
am actually digging the suit. Um,
anyways. While you're shopping
for your ugly sweater,
check out their holiday attire for
yourself or as a gift like adult onesies.
Oh boy. Oh boy, isn't it? Isn't this,
this is a weird time to sell adult Dunk
Onesies, Huh? Is there a picture of the,
of the latest guy would get fucking ousted
out of his career for buying sex toys.
They've even sell wild and crazy ski
suits for you skiers out there for men.
Three piece Christmas suits,
I thumbs up to those interactive sweaters
or they consensually interactive a
beer pong corn hole,
gross and hilarious holiday teas,
uh,
for women holiday leggings. All he
always got a whore it up for you guys.
Sweater dresses and cozy adult onesies.
Specific sizing for men and women so
everyone can get the perfect fit right now
my listeners get 20% off tipsy
elves.com when you use my code bird,
but you are are at checkout. That's 20%
off. Anything you order on the site,
go to [inaudible] dot com enter my
code burr at checkout to get your 20%
sitewide discount. That's tipsy
elves.com and my code, Burr B,
u. R. R. Oh, look who's back. Indochino
talk about how every man looks
better in a suit. You know, guys,
when I sit on the promenade checking
out who's going to be my next boyfriend,
I have to admit I am,
I gravitate to a guy's junk
that's in a three piece suit.
I don't know what it is. I just feel like
he's going to be a little more classy.
Um,
can you can choose from 100,
from hundreds of top quality fabrics
and customized all the details,
including your lapel jacket
lining, monogram, and more.
Indochino has been featured in
major publications including Gq,
Forbes, and the fat. I
think douchebags read Gq.
Don't take what kind of an asshole has
that kind of fucking time to pick out.
Like the perfect pen and pencil set
is what you write out your fucking,
you know, $64 to the electric company,
I'm sorry,
Forbes and fast company and are now
the largest made to measure men's wear
company.
Here's how it works.
Like Gq magazine is for somebody who
fucking wants to act like they're like an
international spy but isn't one,
you know,
they're just kind of fucking old
people out of their pension. I'm sorry.
Anyways, visit a showroom or
online@indochino.com pick your fabric,
choose your customizations
and submit your measurements.
Place your order and wait for it to
arrive. And just a few weeks this week,
my listeners can get any premium
Indochino suit for just 359 yeah.
box@indochino.com uh, when
entering burr at checkout,
that's 50% off the regular price for made
to measure premium suit plus shipping
is free.
indochino.com promo code burr for any
premium suit for just $359 and free
shipping.
Incredible deal for a suit that will fit
you better than anything off the rack.
Ever could,
ah,
back me on ds me on
[inaudible].
Why are we fighting these doses?
But Dude [inaudible] beyond the,
you could go out and I fucking pick Duke,
Bob and lately on this song,
why do I keep doing? I got to
pick an easier word to rhyme with.
[inaudible] just been off my game
lately. You know, me, me undies,
Isis is on a jungle gym due
due due to me on beyond Ds.
We could beat them with the Slim Jim.
Why go down that road every year?
Millions of people receive the least
like gift of all time, underwear,
underwear, right. Even if you get
your wife some sexy underwear,
that's cause kind of a gross gift isn't
it? I guess on some level she psyched.
You're still attractive, but you know
what you really are saying. You know,
I'd come on, you know, what are
you saying? You know what I mean?
I'm surprised feminists haven't
brought that up. Lingerie is slavery.
Um, but we still give it to our families
and our loved ones who just wanted,
isn't that a weird sentence
to just read out of context,
but we still give it to our families and
our loved ones who just don't want it.
It's kind of rapey. Uh, but yeah, maybe
it's not that underwear is the problem.
It's the kind of underwear.
Let me tell you about me.
[inaudible] be on Dee's the only
underwear that makes for an amazing gift.
Mandy's Mandy's May underwear.
The perfect gift at everyone's
going to love for you. You,
it's a God damn holiday.
It's a Goddamn holiday miracle this year.
Don't give me underwear.
Give me undies this holiday season to
get your exclusive 20% off the softest
underwear and socks you'll ever wear.
Free Shipping and 100%
satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot
com slash bird that's me,
undies.com/bar oh my God.
Look who's back.
It's Mvmt movement watches
the holiday season.
Doobie Doobie do is fucking here with
movement watches. You can skip the crowds,
you know, standing behind
that woman with her wide ass.
So anything worse than a wide flat
ass with no signage on it, you know,
at least you could do is fucking,
you know, rent it out, right?
We'll be back with ASCE shaming.
Um,
you could skip the crowds and standing
in crazy lines and find a gift they'll
love at prices that beat
department stores movement watches.
Start at just 95 bucks.
All right.
Just throw it in a stocking handed
to the person. Get on with your life.
Put some bourbon in your Eggnog,
yet done at 35 bucks at a
department store, you're
looking at four to 500 bucks,
sorry, move or watches or just 95
bucks. Edited Department Store.
You're looking at four to 500 bucks.
Yeah.
Uh, for this kind of a watch,
because you can get bought,
we get to watch for like 95 bucks,
but it's like a fucking Timex.
What would figured out
that by selling online,
they were able to cut out the
middleman and retail markup,
providing the best possible price.
Had such great prices.
Movement watches make wonderful
holiday gifts to classic design,
quality construction,
and styled minimalism.
Over 1 million watches
sold in over 160 countries.
It gets 50% off today with free shipping
and free returns by going to movement.
watches.com.
That's M v M t.com.
This watch has a really clean design
that makes a great fashion statement.
Now it's time to step up your watch game.
Go to MVMT watches slash burr.
Join the movement.
All right. Okay. I think, is that
it? I think that's like 28 minutes.
Um,
yeah.
Yeah. I'm going to try,
you know something.
I'm going to try and get out
and do some stand up tonight.
I think I'm going to do that cause I
got some gigs the next couple of nights.
Right. Go out there and
shake the fucking dust off.
I've been in the edit room almost every
night of this week. Okay. Only two nights,
but it felt like every night with my add.
Um,
we are currently editing season
three of f is for family.
Um, I don't know when it's going to be.
It's going to be out later on next year.
Uh, that's how it works. Animation.
It's a very slow process. But um,
I'm really loving all this
season is coming together
and I'm hoping you guys are
too.
And if you don't then I guess we won't
get a season four and if we don't get a
season four, I will be sad. But
I'll also have a lot of free time.
So it's one of those deals. So
who knows, who knows what happens.
So maybe I'll just take the show and
just start fucking putting it up on my
website. Maybe I'll do something like
that. That would be stupid building.
You have to finance it
yourself and you go bankrupt.
Just fucking watch season three so I
could stay with my cushy deal. It Netflix.
Can you do that for me? If not, can you
go to the Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit?
Uh, I'll be announcing more
special guests as we go.
We might have a surprise guest at night.
We're reaching out to some people.
We'll see what happens. Um,
it's always a great night.
We always tell Patrice stories,
we give each other shit and uh,
it's obviously for a great
cause. Okay. That's it.
Please enjoy the music as we transition
into a, an old school Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday, Monday morning podcast
from a Thursday from, I don't know,
years gone by or possibly earlier
this year. I have no idea. That's it.
Have a wonderful weekend.
Uh, you can't and I will,
I will talk to you on Monday.
Okay.
[inaudible]
guys, this youtube video. There we go.
Bill Barr was telling us that he found
a fine video club called best, uh,
best wrestling promos ever starring
this guy. Jump Jeff Farmer.
I'm judging,
I'm guessing that it's from like the 80s,
and this is before Vince Mcmahon sewed
everything up. So it's an independent, uh,
wrestling thing. I don't know. I don't
know where at, but this guy is legit.
So basically what it is, is this guy
jumping Jeff farmers get, you know,
he's going to promote the show.
Jeff Farmer jumping Jeff Farmer,
he's going to promote his big wrestling
match coming up on the Saturday.
He's going to do the ric flair thing.
[inaudible] something.
He's supposed to be doing that shit
and eat it. Might have a little, uh,
a little bit of a tough, tough time.
We've all been spoiled by the, uh,
professionalness of the wrestlers and uh,
how,
how they're able to rock the mic and
really get on there and ad Lib and talk.
And uh, this guy apparently
doesn't have the skills.
He's still in the development phase.
I'm not going to judge this entire career.
Oh, so you got salmon.
He's a wrestling expert
as an expert. I mean, yeah,
Sam will really come running down
the hall of those floppy feet.
We've got to promote that. Kevin Smith's
calling the show today too. Oh yeah.
She'll just keeps getting
better and by Oh my God,
he tweeted awhile ago that he's,
he's sleeping on his phone right now,
so, so they'd wake them up for the,
uh, the interview today. So, uh,
Kevin Smith in about 15, 20 minutes.
All right, let's check this out.
Best Wrestling Promo. Ever earlier
we talked. Good jump in. Joe Farmer.
Let's go now to that interview folks.
There's jump in Jeff Farmer. Yeah.
Lot of back. What a Matthew
had with mildly. Yup.
Probably the hardest back
I ever had in my life
when things aren't going my way.
Motley Crue,
he turned the tables on me.
You turned the tables in a wrong way.
You got me mad.
Now I'll turn it around.
I've listened to everything you had
to say. I did everything necessary.
When you turn around and you back fed me
one way or another and you take me out
of what rightfully mine.
When I get angry,
now I'm the one doing the challenging.
I'm issuing a challenge for you.
Motley crews get in the
ring with me this time
going full bore.
Go Up and Joe Farmer
Jumping Jeff.
That guy is [inaudible].
That is the worst intro ever got
your ass kicked last week. Yup. Yup,
Yup.
Motley crews,
the panic on his face like he
looks like he's going to laugh,
but that's what I was supposed to,
I was supposed to go on with this shit.
He looks like he's going to piss himself
with math.
I was saying he played the fake
staying in one point. Is that True Sam?
Does he look familiar?
I don't think so.
He never had a career in wrestling really.
Someone was trying to say he's
in the wrestling hall of fame,
the w whatever the F, whatever
that is. Awe. Oh thing.
[inaudible] he's an IPW fucking get
Sam started. He'll till school. Yon Am.
I thought you knew everybody.
The refi arrests now how can it around?
I've lifted into everything. You
know that guy? Oh no, go ahead.
You had another guy. What are
you doing? Then you had to say,
oh, give a list of when you turn around
and you back there me one way or another,
and you treat me out of what's
rightfully mine. That when I get angry,
now I'm the one doing the challenging.
I'm issuing a challenge to you.
Motley crews get in the ring with me.
Um,
going bull horn,
go up and Joe Farmer, that
guy's classic too, by the way.
Find a way. All Wrestling Promo
bloopers are, she's a genius and
Great Kim Proterra. It's just fantastic.
Some bloopers out there, dude.
Have you ever seen the one where booker
t calls Hong Kong in the n word and then
grabbed his head because he's humiliated?
[inaudible] calls Tony Atlas a black
boy back when he was a thunder lips.
Oh, this one's great. Yeah. What's the
right here?
I should
[inaudible] best is when he turns around.
He looks at the girl and his crew like,
Vince is going to kill us.
[inaudible]
I should
[inaudible] which he
should have been able to
[inaudible] his character.
Genius. Genius. LEX Luger's genius.
The Lex Luger blooper right there.
[inaudible] slugger one
[inaudible]
the best part is he goes to cover his
face and then he makes it look like he's
rubbing his hands together.
He's thinking maybe this will fly
after all, so I got to cover up.
I just fucked up the whole time he's
got his chest, his pecs, doing that,
moving up and down.
This one's good because it's taken,
like when they do smack down,
they'd tape it to rebroadcast
and they edited sometimes. Yeah,
but if you have a satellite dish,
you can pick up the satellite
feed and watch it live.
So they got the satellite feed of Hong
Kong and just completely like fucking
starting over,
but okay.
Oh,
he messes up in front of the him.
The fact that I had something to do with
building this company just makes you
sick.
The fact that I am the one that
put this company on the map,
it helps you make it what it is today.
That makes you sick to
your stomach brother.
Yeah,
we're all those weird sets that you have.
All those billions of dollars,
the houses that your kids live in,
the $20 million they case your
home and blah blah blah, blah.
Like just shut up because
of these maniacs. Shut up
just by half
fucking Vince
[inaudible] the tell you something.
Either you're starting to believe
in your own bullshit. Hogan.
I could have had anybody
play the part of whole token.
I could have had anybody bring whole on
one second McMahon.
You actually think anybody
could have ran with Hulkamania.
Look at all the guys you gave the ball
to look at all the guys that had the bell
with all the guys that red to the go on.
Nobody ran as hard and as
long as I didn't make man.
Sounds like a real argument.
Sweet thing.
If you actually think I was just
the right guy at the right place,
if the raw at the right time.
Let me say it one more time
so you completely understand.
If you actually believe,
I don't mind if you actually think
that I was just the right gay guy.
Right place at the right time.
Well then Europe liger delusional bastard
that I thought you weren't Mcmann,
right? Gay. Yes.
Campania going wild and
do what I say right now,
man.
Right now we just settled
a couple of weeks ago.
They just paddling and you were the
one that I wanted to get in the ring.
You were the one
holy mother's gun goes off forever
saying what happened.
This is why would you do
this? You're losing them, man.
We got to get bid here.
Closing them.
You go with the fucking board minutes
that they really did mess up didn't they?
Yeah. What the fuck is sounded
like a regular pillow to me.
He said,
and this is good.
You've got to make up with the a little
girl and the Kemper terror one. Dude,
that one next.
All right,
Lex Luger.
Mr Luger, Mr Luger I saw was just
had been out there with Ron Killins.
I just want to ask you,
I mean,
what are your plans for the next show
is super bowl Saturday. I mean, are you,
are you going to take care of Ron Killins?
What kind of disgusting?
This spill.
This clickable lack of respect.
Does that Billy, what's his name?
Show book it on match for the total
package. Lex Luger and super brawl.
Super Saturday. What is it?
No, you know, let's call them
super bosses Saturday. Can you
afford to pay me and Russell wrong?
I don't know. I'm going to look
pretty sledding stars there with God
and you book a marriage with me. You guys
like killings. Look at me. I'm a package.
I
will rip him apart.
Piss down. Fuck that up.
Oh,
I don't think I'd,
I stunk royally you the interview
where he has his whole costume on,
but his voice is just
regular regular voice.
Don't do the point.
What's that? What's that one saying? This
was Kim. Tara. Tara with fucking gene.
They continental title for less
than 48 hours. What's Oh coffee.
Come to the point where few completely.
It's really Hurghada hand [inaudible]
head, man. I May. There's going squad.
Dang Palm Sunday. Riley Ray's Hercules
Hernandez, Mr. Wonderful Paul on dark.
I've been familiar with before.
I'm throwing a million of you right
now in the third that there my bad.
I didn't want to you with
me like a 30 yard dog
and the goon squad.
I didn't pay pain.
I can re fabric cover while
you recuperate by beyond that.
I am told
watch gene opened.
She go into the bed,
got it going on in the world
wrestling federation, gene of Europe.
I think he was laughing when
he said 30 yard dumpster here.
It's a matter of time. Like
I said before, I thought,
you mean can I pled to everybody?
It's just a matter of time like that.
But tell her, get them fall here
and run the world record. Right.
The World Wrestling Federation.
[inaudible] hey, paint.
Go on Fridays personally,
one door.
You're all gonna go down one by one
and I'm gonna make sure that we're the
weapon that you gave me. Let me like
on read, said it right. Redhead,
[inaudible] tracking of
that's want to do good.
Turn around.
Yeah, right. Great. I'm going
to carry the cards for awhile,
but I do and I view all right,
a little too visual because
[inaudible] this,
someone's been a, this is,
this sounds really good,
but there's a couple of things coming in.
A botch mania on youtube and
shock master. Yeah, shock master.
You've seen it before. I think shock
master roster mania is very visual, but a,
okay, 10 labs in my life, I'm
shocked. Master's up their shop.
It might be in the top five. Shock Master.
This is my favorite one. It's Cyco city.
He doesn't realize he's
live. Okay. All y'all fans,
but there are a lot of skeptics that
think that perhaps you can't take it.
How do you address those skeptics?
All the skeptics and all the people
that have a little bill five house.
Sorry, live pal or answer tonight. Well,
they're here to man or keyword.
Psycho said back to you.
You're live is as, let me do
that again. Yeah. We covered.
Phoned our man of few words.
You start words.
This is a the shock master. What does
it look, man? What's the set up on that?
Basically they were the first version of
it. Oh Rick flair. They were supposed to,
uh, they had a mystery partner and you
were supposed to be like the next big,
a good guy in WCW.
Yeah.
And he was supposed to bust through the
wall but nobody told him there was a
support to buy for under like
at the base of the wall. Yeah.
So he trips right over the two
by four falls flat on his face.
Got Ahead staying the entire thing is
the funniest thing you've ever seen.
It's staying in the British
bulldog or horrendous.
They were supposed to big this
big pump up the shot master.
But when he fought,
I'm Tom when ric flair,
cause he's one of the greatest of all
time at this surrounded by five bombs.
Awful.
And his reaction to what happened,
I watched this 700 times in the
Shag cry every time. Shock Master.
He was just an old wrestler
from the date of UAE, from,
he was tugboat and Dadada I remember you
said they put a storm trooper helmet,
literally a storm trooper helmet.
Did they covered in glitter?
All sparkles and always make
sure you have the, the, the,
the sting lead in Iowa Soda. You
know, this was actually so bad.
Did this guy had a whole gimmick. He
was going to be the next main event guy.
They changed his entire gimmicks so that
he was just a Klutz that always lost.
They couldn't do anything with it
after that because of his debut. Yeah.
Our partner is going to be
none other than,
hey
miss,
please
tell me what happened.
All ready.
I'll like go on the wall and then he
lost his helmet and how to go get it and
put it back on his head. He covers his own
face, so it's like, that's his gimmick.
The way is there.
The waffle,
like a pot of glittered potted
plants on top was fucking head.
Do you think other wrestlers laughed
at him for this? Gone voice was done.
His voice was done by a guy who
the said who had a live Mike all,
they didn't tape it. He did it live.
So when he trips you can hear them go,
Oh God no.
That was ric
flair. He goes, let me
tell you something. If
you watched the whole thing would at home,
you gotta understand the Harlem Harlem,
he who would just fuck.
He was doing a promo.
Vicious,
vicious was going to band from it.
Now we just watched too bad promos.
British bulldog and staying.
We'll awful and ric flair had,
this was like the Rick flesh show so he
was trying to put this together and Rick
Flash turn them. But, but when, when
he fell through the wall, ric Flair,
when, Oh God, that fall,
the greatest thing that
has forever and slow shit.
How bad the promo with up to that point
panicked grabbing for that helmet.
This is in front of an audience, Yo Yo
this a live audience and it's live on TV.
It's like this is their big
thing leading up to a paper view.
Live television by the paper view.
So you could see this guy make you
think that was supposed to be his debut.
He fits
this
perfectly clear. They're expecting
big things from the shock man.
But you have state maybe the next hole,
Stengel for a shock,
right it completely chin. Yet. For the
most part it ended. Just get to stay on.
If you have it wrestles,
he wrestled.
Click the audio is a little low
on this. This is the best. Yeah.
Bare with us around it a little further.
She could get some more lead up
admissions. Bad Promo. Yeah.
No,
they're all nervous cause flares
there where it's just like disgusting.
Oh my God.
Is he yelling?
That's the brace boob. I'm talking about.
The
worst outfit I've ever
seen you have is listed.
It looks like he's wearing
a pumpkin on his head. Fuck.
You have to understand what?
Oh he said what? Tough. Oh my God
is held up
shaking his head.
He's gotta put his helmet on because the
other guy's going to do his promo forum
so you can see his mouth
shot.
It's in the top left
just because it's like, it's not
even a regular rest. If statements,
the shock master
Paul is supposed to break through.
I watched,
I watched this live in 1993 it's the
greatest moment in pro wrestling history.
There's never been a better time.
It's killing me.
Eight different things
that are making you think.
They watched this and just laugh.
They did.
It completely destroyed his career.
Now not only do you have to,
you have to be as quiet as you can because
you can hear Rick flair say, Oh God.
Then you can hear offset
where he's supposed to.
We're getting ready to
do his promo for them.
You can hear them making fun of him.
Okay,
let's try to be
funny to laugh to yourself if you can.
Just fucking fat.
Gut of
day.
I've been through them.
I was trying to drill a hole I made.
You know what,
and we're doing his costume
of injustice. Yeah. He had a,
for a giant fur vest that was
three quarter lane with no buttons,
giant sparkly helmet and jeans and boots
and no shirt shop master.
The shock pastor was in the ass.
They literally, after this show,
they changed his entire gimmick.
He became a construction worker
that constantly falls down.
That was his career
on bell's Palsy.
The stroke master tapes,
having them.
Okay guys,
shock mess the rules.
I don't think I give you her license and
she's the greatest thing I've ever seen.
Tony Smoke. Okay. Everybody
contained so high. We'll try.
It's like big Jack,
our partner.
You're
my boy.
His voice has started yet.
You see him,
you see them motioning with his hands,
but his voice didn't start yet.
The guys behind stage isn't talking yet.
He's just motioning like he's
talking like he's a mine.
None of them said you fell
through the wall. I'm like, Yo,
she impressed with this guy to
be able to yell without laughing.
He's so bad. He probably
didn't know. Still
don't know muscles at all. He's
just heritable shots. Reducer
on tight. Get chickens. I had
to have my stomach stapled.
I keep breaking the wall and falling.
I wish we could hear the audio better.
I was trying to nail a foundry logo to
the Ali's pummel you with how cupcakes
are made.
Dvds.
He fell and this is the thing too,
if you,
you fell no hands on his head like
flat on his fucking fucking stupid
helmet and his elbow and fallen.
He's got down on the fucking floor
like a fish sand pail on his head.
Oh
No.
Stopping him to do when
he put the helmet back on.
I love the fact that he's staying at,
he has to wipe the grounder off his head
hurt and look at staying is bad.
All I have to say is he's calming
everybody down. Here's the moment.
All I have to say is all part
is going to shock. So word
my ro ro was off.
Timing was
I got to see it again.
You get to talk Yo. Yeah.
Do you want to hear it was good. It's
really hard in here. The whole outfit.
Everything a mistake.
He doesn't ever been body terrible.
Hello.
Wait, stop it. Stop it. Stop
it. Stop it. Stop it. I'm
sorry. You gotta understand too.
If this was sid vicious in Harlem heat
and they were beaten up British bulldog,
a sting for like months and this is
the guy who Dan is going to match the
intensity.
These are the top three guys,
the top bad guys in the company
versus the top good guys.
They had no one with him. And then
the day. Then this is the guy.
They fucking got to stop
it on slide Doron foot
or less. Most of them do you? I would
love to know what they're, what,
like what is the shock best
you're thinking after his
helmet goes on, he's like,
I just ran the
big ball
all.
I wish I could see that from behind him.
Shot red zone is the best
on somebody tweeted that.
They made fun of this on raw recently.
Yeah, we get it with the club show.
I can get you to clap right
here. All right, good. Yeah.
Supposedly they went real inside
and made fun of this one wrong.
It's about a year ago. Less
than a year ago. All right.
Here's one more from the shock master.
Yeah.
None other than,
hey,
he just felt there's no two
by four that he just fell
and everybody,
we got to,
we got on here.
Wait a minute.
This is what he's doing.
He's waiting for that guy to
start driving and when he yells,
he thinks it's his voice.
Pantomiming the was yelling at him.
He thinks that it's his voice.
His uh, backstage voice guy,
but it's not if the guy,
and he can't even pay to mind
is this five seconds,
which seems like a million years where
everyone is collecting themselves.
So for 10,
this shit did audience,
the front flap,
the shot master,
hello.
Everybody went holy Shit.
His helmet.
So discombobulated.
What he's hearing is where he's
supposed to be saying they're all,
here's a storm trooper helmet. He
got that down a Halloween. Yes. Yes.
It's not an exaggeration.
It's the storm,
the storm trooper helmet with Glen
Brown. Anyway, until the next style,
he got the captain caveman and cap
as genes that he drove to the arena.
And I think I heard a better version from
the guy that just tweeted me. Hey Man,
I gotta I gotta pick up at nine 45.
I got to go to the airport.
You've got to go bill. Yeah. I,
Bob Gilbert came by to say hi
and we bring in La. Oh yeah,
he's gone back to [inaudible].
I will, I will be back, uh,
next week. Yeah, next week.
Hopefully. Yeah. Asap. Already time. He'll
be back on the show next week. All right.
Thank you Mr Bern. Keep up the podcast.
I'm a big fan belt. Take it easy.
Oh, there it goes. This shot. They're all
looking at and go into shock messages.
Fell through. They all see the
whole gear going down the toilet.
Could you go back?
Could you go into shock master on Rod?
Just see if it's a better clip
shot. Master on Ra is, is the,
is the shock master on wrong? Like that's,
that's the one they made fun of him.
That's not the original shock master.
Yeah,
they have a clip of it though in the
beginning just to set it up. All right.
What'd you go with this? I just to that
the audio [inaudible] to hear his promo.
Yeah,
let's go.
No, go. [inaudible]
so you're that man.
Call me the shock master.
But you just felt you want the world that
come on. Are you on a
patient? Maybe they want to
comment that got master race.
I'm ready.
Hello.
Can you pause this glitter?
I think he has a glitter
storm trooper helmet
on his chest from when he fell
and got that fucking storm trooper
helmet sparkles. All local.
I think it's coming.
And why did it sit?
All scared of him cause
he looked all scared.
Why did he turn around and Douche bag?
He just fell through the fucking wall.
Shock master is a dud.
And then the promo is terrible and
embarrassing. Be this brutal villain.
This guy from another planet. Oh
my God. Jeans and boots and uh,
and and, and, and there's always the
first thing you see is him falling.
You on want a patient? Me, I just fell
through the wall. Oh motherfucker.
That is so funny.
Now what is the set up on this now is
this is from 19 or 2009 it was a year ago.
They made fun. Oh, much better
audio. His Promo on this phone.
None other than shock.
Rob Scott.
Oh God.
Yeah.
You heard someone say,
what did he 40 40 for the low voice.
What did he has by stage?
Roy's Alemany fall. Oh,
I love this guy.
None other than me shocked.
I told you,
Oh God,
no,
go
told you it's just so bad.
It's everything about is poorly done.
Everything man,
that was added from the original
one there just cut out some awkward.
Oh yeah. And then one thing
I noticed, yeah, this is when
they, uh, and then Rod, uh,
did a spoof on it a year ago.
Yeah. Cause they were putting out,
when was the original shock
master? 1993. I saw the fucking 17,
almost 17 years later. Raw fucking goofed
on here. Let's see how they goofed on.
No, but where's that coming from?
I think it's coming from that
wall or your voters. You know,
it sounds like it's coming
from over here. Yeah. Hmm.
Whoa. No smart.
Awesome.
Show you.
Where's the,
where's the voice that voice
young for? I don't know. You know,
it sounds like it's coming from
right over there. Oh, there it
is.
A crap.
Did they anyone even get it?
Brands. I love the shock. Master
Clinton. Yeah. Oh yeah. It's,
that is out of [inaudible] member. A
lot of labs. I had that shock mashed up.
That's great. And then they
were dusty rose. Who is,
who was probably in the top five,
like Mike guys of all time
to like dusty flare flair.
Always the best. Was the rock
the best mic guy? No, not at all.
Not probably not even. He might not
even be the top five. Really? Yeah.
He was great though. He
was fantastic. Dusty.
Ric flair. Flair is better than
Roddy Piper. Um, hi, my name five.
Uh,
I'm trying to think.
I said that was the rock was good at
making catch phrases. How about sergeants?
No, no. Um, oh my Jake.
The snake isn't in the top of the
top five probably. And um, you know,
not the rock is not in the top five.
Top 10 stone hall was probably better
on the Mike in the Rocco's if probably
that's the five, right? The Rock.
We just going to make an catchphrases
and then he does is the best though.
Dusty and flare are neck and neck
also. See One, they're all saying,
oh and hard. Had a really good one.
Really good blooper. Uh, well, yeah,
the best food for a long time, but
come on. Oh, that's terrible. I,
I was saying that damn a goddamn shock
master do that is one of the bed that is
hysterical. Oh, I like on, we
able to laugh until I come.
Actually fucking tears coming
down my eyes. You didn't
try the on her one. Funny.
I just recently stopped watching it like,
yeah,
but you still watch it
with this thing like wow.
You went right on his fucking head is
the worst thing that could have happened.
The worst thing,
dude right there and the helmet falling
off and he scrambles to put it on and
it's so clumsy and then he's just
standing there trying to be tough.
Be tough with all the
glitter on his chest.
[inaudible]
beauty. The surrounds, Right
Lisa? She's very pissed off. She
really? Yeah, she, Lisa and Jersey.
Lisa.
Yes.
Hi Lisa.
I just chose the product of woman.
He's wet.
I just can't believe that
women fall for his crew.
Oh, you're an easy mark.
Listen to you. Yeah.
I would get you with within within
two days of knowing me you'll,
you'll be subscribing yet, right? Yeah.
Just by your man. Just by your answer,
Sweetie. I can tell you go. This
is classic. Yeah, right. Whatever.
Here's what [inaudible] is on your mind.
I'm an big arrogant,
big mouth fucking ass hole,
right? And you want to curb,
you want to destroy that any way you can.
So here's what you do.
If you're a pretty, this is when pretty
girls fuck up. Did they try to hear,
hear a giggling is this is,
here's what pretty girls fuck up.
They try to get me because
I'm a fat motherfucker.
So what they try to do is
they play the love game.
They give me something they think
is precious, which is plus he,
that's what girls have
to give. But after that,
that can on attack mode,
you have a plan.
Can you have other than your Plessy on it,
if you want to,
if you want to destroy a man's fucking
arrogance, what do you do to do that?
Other than use your pussy.
Yeah.
Oh my God. Oh my God. I
hear what she's doing.
The singing because she didn't really
don't have an answer. Oh my God.
It's like, what else can you do?
Talk about fucking a fringe memory.
Ever with me yet. What you
mainly talk about that? Yes.
I could in Nagley in mainly, here's
what you got to understand, ma'am.
We don't like you no matter what you know,
we don't care if you know all the
quarterbacks in NFL, we don't know.
We don't care if you
know every team color,
we don't care if you know all the GMS.
We don't care if you
know every basketball,
we don't care because it
mainly we don't like you,
so you try to infiltrate
your personalities on us
and you realize that you're
not interested in. Then you try
to fuck us when that doesn't work.
Your hours. Okay. Okay.
You're interested in it at first and
then look at if I work hard to get what I
want, which is pussy. Right. You agree
with that? That we work hard to get pussy,
right? Yes. What he did at the,
I do what I do. What's your job?
Oh, you did. Don't you
like the companionship or
well, yes, but in a, in a possession
kind of way, like, like you,
you go wash this girl cheat. You know
what women have to do grow on you.
My girl been around for four
years. Grow on you. Oh my God. Yes.
You love what you girlfriend you love.
I imagine that you're
dating an intelligence.
Beautiful. She's a genius. Really. She's
fucking genius girl. I begged doctors,
lawyers, teachers, people tell you I don't
pay no fucking homeless people. Retards.
No one that dates on Paxil
or no shit like that.
He's telling you, she's telling you
that she just had a miscarriage.
That sounds like an intelligent woman.
Oh, well that's a goofy bitch.
But that's, that's the bitch.
You fuck when you just meet the visuals,
the lactaid
got a miscarriage. That's,
that's the, that's the,
that's the price you pay when you
meet a bitch on off the street.
That was a snack for procure.
I'm just talking about like,
like the girl I went to dinner,
we would go out to dinner,
you and curse me out for a little while.
You would,
you would understand because you innately,
you don't have your own philosophy cause
you're not really saying anything now.
Yeah. You waited when Patrice brought
up the fact that uh, the pussies,
the weapon when they go with, when you
girls go into battle for the first time,
this is before any get to know you
get to know you, whatever. It's just,
that's why we know that's all
you want in the beginning.
Well that's all we want, but in the
beginning that's not all I want to listen.
That's all you got now. Are you good?
Is Pussy. Why would I try to phone
sounded like that. You
sound like, you know,
this is the way I keep
her on track and this is
yes. I'm like, look at my
look at your mouth like that.
You can tell there's no guidance in
your life because you're too comfortable
yapping about nothing.
Yeah,
okay. For sure. Nothing
all the time. Right?
Because I'm a guy and that's what we do.
But you,
the stuff you talk about
that you think is about some
talk constantly. Constantly. Thank you.
But it's always interesting when
guys talk. All Right Lisa, thank you.
We got a couple more here. Let's go to
Kevin and Nebraska. Kevin. Bye guys.
Jump in.
Find your spot and go,
hi doctor on man, you need to shut
off. My wife was to this show.
You're giving away all my stuff.
I'm sorry man. I only get no good soldiers
in trouble. But this the statement,
let's go right to Colorado.
Kirsten, what's up?
Hey, I totally agree with Patrice.
Absolutely agree with Patrice.
Women need to know their place.
No.
What they do do it well and please
their math and their man will be around
forever. Good girl. Wow.
Or ever. Absolutely.
Men need a writer to be a writer. It's
not that difficult. Keep your mouth shut.
Do what you're told.
Be who you are.
Is that what you're saying? Is that
what you do with your girl? Oh,
thank you. Karsten let's go
to John and Utah. John Deep
Voice. Yeah. That's just one
treat. Saved my marriage. I was the, uh,
the doting the doting husband and
was solid. It was all about her,
uh, start, listen to him and things were,
were going bad. So I started going, Whoa,
whoa. The trees do. I
started following his advice.
What would Patrice
first, but it's turned around and
work happier than we could possibly.
No Way. Your job, when you see
t shirts, here's what he said,
he's here when he said we're happy.
A happy man is a happy relationship.
A happy woman is a miserable man.
Wow.
You want it?
She wanted me to be the man.
That's what fucking point is.
You got to do a one shot deal,
a relationship advice show for the
shot, like one hour, two hours,
whatever you want to handle it.
This is just simple. We'll, we'll,
we'll work that out with Washington. We'll
get Patrice on on the show by himself.
Just taking calls. Why your relationships?
Here's why you can and here's why.
You should always understand
why is legitimate.
I'm a fucking mess physically.
Like I'm trauma trying to get in
shape one these days but naked,
if you look at me naked next to my
girl, you will go, what the fuck?
Like my self esteem has to like when I
fuck I have to go. Why is she fucking me?
I would never give me no pussy and
it's like I'm looking at it going,
what's she up to?
This is like my low self esteem.
He gotta be an ulterior motive.
My self esteem is so low is high.
I go, what is this bitch after? But I
started realizing it's a mind thing.
All they want, all they want is just a
motherfucker they can look at and blink,
slow and respect and anyway,
it's not about beating them
in and subjugating them.
It's about they look at you and feel
like they don't need to be your Mama.
That's it. They go, wow this
motherfucker is in my corner.
He handles his business,
you know said this is what I'm saying.
You'll house situation.
You become a million times
sexier cause that's a man.
Shit you did is buy a fucking mansion.
That's a mansion.
You bought a mansion Anthony.
So it's like your girl can't help it go
this mother fucker when you're renting,
she can kind of that other half of
her voice that tries to put you down.
She can look at you and
go this faggot in Renton.
It 59 but now it's like
snake written a house pussy ass N***a,
you bought a mansion again. Clothes.
She wants you more 59 finally,
you're hotter than you was when you
was written. It's a fat fuck man. Wow.
That's really good. Hey, uh wait.
Hold on man. Let's go to John. Jay,
you got, you got people, man
reacted. Oh, John and Pennsylvania.
Hi Patrice.
I'm a bread.
You know how to keep you over
the line without a contract.
Yeah man, it's my shit. Dude is
mine. I'm telling you. It's like,
it's like it's pimping without beaten.
I'm Megan to sell pussy.
It's just stay one back dude.
Don't ever let him convince it on one day.
What will they do without
like a man's guidance?
You haven't seen a woman at once.
Like they try to,
you see how did success to a woman is
doing is being like a guy. It's like, I,
I do this, I do Vat, I
do listen vac and, and,
and we can care less like a sexy man.
Like fuck it.
I'm a female ob like a woman,
a woman as in same
position that is always in,
is not any sexier than the bitch that
works at Mcdonald's. If she's cute.
That's the thing about us. We don't point.
Very good point. I'll see a woman walk.
A lot of people are calling you the
black doctor, Phil black doctor.
That's the name of your show. We're going
to get to choose like one or two hours.
How it goes.
Black seal.
There's black doctor Phil with
Patrice O'neil as Philip. Alright,
Don's listening. We got to set that up.
You want to do a, I don't know when,
when would it make sense?
It sounds like get my fucking hole,
my straight like that.
Just go off with a on an improper turn
on the freaking channel and just let the
phones rang and see what
happens for an hour. Yeah,
we'll we'll set that up in the very near
future. Let's go to turtle from WAC. Pag.
Turn off.
Hey guys, listen. Patrice,
you're absolutely right.
I've been jumping through hoops ever since
I met my wife trying to get the pussy
and once you got it,
they put up more hoops to jump through.
I got to go home and implement
the o' Neil standard in my own,
the Neil standard.
Wow.
She knows eventually you're going to
figure out if she doesn't constantly apply
pressure that you're going to figure
out. Holy Shit. What? Like my man,
he was nervous that his wife
was going to leave him and I go,
let me ask you a question. Like if
you really, if we really sit down,
if my woman left Yo woman left Illumina,
you go, what would you really miss them
exactly like what would you miss?
It's your own arrogance.
Our arrogance is men because
their possessions and if
they leave it's like, um,
it's like losing your favorite pencil,
but it's like Penn is waiting,
waiting, a relationship,
loving relationship in years.
Maybe your favorite favorite print
doesn't even sound like it's a number two
pencil stuff.
[inaudible] Betty
[inaudible] we break peaches
[inaudible]
[inaudible].